Salam alaikum guys like him Salam I am
very excited we just finished our
presentation and we had that was Chris
right yes Chris just accepted Islam this
is a gift and I'm meeting Norman the
Norman North nope normally not a Dean
nor a Dean and you also you accepted
Islam how long ago a year and five
months ago at hamdulillah
where are you from Georgia Mattoon
Illinois now to tell us in short what
was it about Islam that captivated you
and had you accepted I met many friends
from Egypt and as time went by I just
started learning a little bit more about
Islam and it started making more sense I
was a Christian my family is at
Christian Christians and it just made
much more sense and I connected with it
I never really connected with the
Christianity too much but when I started
going to the Masjid and learning more
about Islam and going through Ramadan
it makes so much more sense and I just
got drawn into and it hamdulillah I'm a
Muslim
so you're an American yes both of the
United States military tell us about how
it was in the United States Navy I was
on board the USS Kitty Hawk I was in
Desert Storm and Desert Shield I went in
an 89 and then got out of active duty in
92 and I had a major motorcycle accident
when I was in the reserve and I lost my
right arm and for many years I was
always wondering why why would this
happen to me
but alhamdulillah as time went by I was
able to take care of my father and
during that time is when I found Islam
as well he just died like two weeks
before I took my Shahada so
alhamdulillah for everything now what
are some of the challenges that you've
faced you know some people they and
liking Japanese cars you know some
people like German cars you know that
doesn't consider someone at radar now
right some people like Spanish for you
maybe they're from Italy you know we see
this growing now because someone wants
to worship the Creator not the creation
they accept Islam you didn't change your
DNA you're still in America another
American American Bosnian heritage but
you see a lot of this ignorance but when
people see the connection that we have
with Jesus they see the connection that
we have in any other part of the
province of the Bible the simple message
of Islam you know they resonates with
them what experiences have you had like
this with ignorant people and then how
were you able to dispel some of these
myths I don't really call them ignorant
or dismiss informed so you know and the
media portrays a lot of different things
and a lot of people don't understand the
Quran they think they do you know if
you're gonna read it in English and some
of my friends would say they read the
Quran in
and you know they don't like what it
says but but what we decided you know it
should read it in at least five
different versions to get the context of
that my family some of them were shocked
you know when I did bad things before
Islam you know I used to drink a little
bit in odds-and-ends nobody cared but
when I took the Shahada they're like oh
they're brainwashing you but I sit down
with them and alhamdulillah my family is
fine my aunts are fine and they've met
many Egyptians and they also are
donating to some some charitable events
in Egypt as well now because of this so
it's it's awesome what advice I mean
Europe you're a patriot you're someone
who who fought for your country yes
right you're a born bred an American
you're still in America but you're just
a Muslim like Jesus was you still love
Jesus yes yes of course what advice do
you have for others they've been
watching the Deen show you know they've
been learning a little bit about Islam
they're seeing past like you said
they're misinformed what else what
advice do you give for people who are
searching for purpose and now they
connect with you rather than maybe
someone who's Egyptian Moroccan or
whatever for you and as an American what
advice do you have for them it shouldn't
is the biggest thing the advice is if
you have a question to ask somebody that
that's a Muslim if we don't have the
answer we will find the answer for you
just patience and understanding that
don't listen to the media all the time
because some of their information is
wrong or or people that are not Muslims
if a lot of times people criticize it
and they don't know nothing about Islam
they just it's just hearsay and ours
what they heard or what somebody has
said or what they've seen on TV and it's
it's it's sad because it's nothing
ninety-nine percent of time it's not the
truth so be patient ask questions and
we're more than happy to talk with you
if we don't know the answer we will find
the answer but we're all human or it's
one world we believe in the same God God
in Allah is the same many times when you
say a lot of people like panic
it's the same gun it's just a different
language it's very simple
well it's a pleasure thank you for
coming to the talk here is really nice
to meet you
and they'll all continue to bless you
mr. Bashar your short story thank you
guys for tuning in keep tuning in to
learn more 1 800 662 Islam Salaam
Aleichem - about peace be with you
watch the game show lost detail make
sure you watch the news show watch the
Dean show watch the Dean show watch the
Dean show watch the future